hello everyone we'll be starting
here in just a few more minutes so thank
you for joining and please be patient we
have another five minutes until we start
hello everyone thank you for joining we
will be starting
uh in a way
all right let's get started i think we
can begin
yes yeah i think we can begin and others
can join in the meantime
okay welcome everyone to this webinar
and thank you for joining today
today's topic is data science omics
logic data science so how is data
science different from
bioinformatics and what we typically
speak about is bioinformatics and
application into different types of data
into different domains biomedical data
today we are going to be talking about
the
more technical aspects of this upcoming
program
and how you can benefit from actually
gaining
a lot of the technical skills in
coding in statistical analysis and
machine learning
and really see the application of these
methods not just
at the conceptual level but actually
from learning about
why and how to pick specific methods all
the way to implementation
so i will be introducing the program but
together with me
dr harpietko or clinton kunha
will be taking on different sessions and
so before we begin
i will just briefly introduce omixlogic
and what is it that we typically do
so as i mentioned our focus is on
biology as a data science so we speak a
lot about the applications
of data analysis to high throughput data
and training that we provide to elevate
the level of biomedical research
and also enable research by providing
specific benefits in application to
oncology studies infectious diseases
neuroscience as well as agriculture and
so one of the connecting
dots between all of these are the
applications of data science methods
and so today we'll talk a little bit
more in depth on that topic
but typically we provide research
enablement through
analysis of big data so we actually have
big data analysis tools that are
designed to address
challenges in processing analysis
visualization and integration of
different types of omics data and
phenotypic data
we provide mentorship where you can
interact with our mentor community and
actually
get one-on-one private mentorship if you
need
in application to different types of
data and we also provide the synchronous
training resources so we have a
collection of courses
and programs organized with
collaborators
and different types of university high
school level as well as college level
training that we provide so let me go on
and briefly introduce this topic of data
science so what exactly is data science
data science
is the ability to work with data
so manipulate data organize data and
that is
informatics and then to apply meaningful
statistical analysis techniques to this
data which include
different types of machine learning and
statistical analysis and even
visualization so it's really
analysis of that data and then finally
you have this
application of these methods and all
this data to a particular domain
or a specialization and when we speak
about data science in general data
science
tends to be agnostic so data science
methods just
knowing how to run analysis could be
applied to very many different domains
clinical business internet of things
finance and marketing biological
research
but specifically if we talk about
biological data
there's going to be a specific uh
additional
level of specialization that we need to
discuss and that will be
the way that data is generated and
therefore what are the specific
questions that are being asked of that
particular data set
and how can we later on interpret it
because as opposed to
other types of data a lot of times
biological data is
much more challenging to enter
to interpret and to understand
the technical versus the biological
patterns that we find in this data and
those are critical to distinguish
as we see to find interpretable
meaningful insights from this kind of
data
so the omics logic data science program
is designed to provide an overview of
statistical analysis and machine
learning methods
to discuss experimental design and some
of the technical variation that we need
to address
before the data is analyzed how to mine
data for meaningful patterns and what do
we mean by associations
and then also the application of
complex biomedical or biological systems
using big data so how do we infer these
relationships
from data and how do we interpret them
in the context of this
complexity of biological systems and so
specifically this program is going to be
focused on
machine learning for biomedical
discovery specifically we'll talk about
what data science and bioinformatics are
designed to do and how can you
learn the conceptual approaches but also
the practical skills
we will talk about data processing
cleaning and exploration
the application of data science and
biomedicine so what types of
projects and what types of examples are
going to be meaningful for this kind of
analysis and then we'll introduce
machine learning algorithms for next
generation sequencing
we'll talk about data mining in the
context of
x omics integration or the integration
between different types of omics data
and how to apply deep learning
and clinical phenotype annotation for
some of the advanced methods of analysis
that
are being discussed and sometimes used
in the context of omics data
okay so i see that a couple of messages
here that people are mentioning that
they cannot hear
unfortunately i think that is probably
because of your connection or setting so
if you could try and rejoin
uh and so narika maybe you could post
this message also in chat if people
cannot hear so
specifically i think that in the context
of biomedical discovery right we're
talking about
the different aspects of biomedical
discovery where
machine learning and the analytics have
to be contextualized
because we are going to be trying to
connect the research question or the
clinical or biomedical
need and challenge to different levels
of statistical analysis and exploratory
analysis that allow us to connect this
to the type of data that is being
generated
that essentially represents some kind of
a biological experiment
even though this experiment could also
be a design
of a data collection without a specific
experimental condition
but more in the real world sense and so
specifically in the real world
sense what types of data are we
typically talking about
so as we move into this era of precision
medicine we typically
mean that there's some kind of a
phenotype at the top of the iceberg
at the level where we can see and
observe the symptoms
and then underneath we have this
molecular data
that we need to connect to the clinical
data in order for us to be able to
integrate the signal and extract some
meaningful
results and so obviously in the context
of
biomedical discovery we're talking about
biomedical applications that
include treatment and selection of
treatment options stratifying risks for
patients
but also we're talking about the
application for drug discovery
and for clinical trials and so in drug
discovery
this analysis of big data from clinic
clinical data as well as from high
throughput experiments
can speed up the development and the
translation of discoveries to
the use by patients but also in clinical
trials it's an important component to be
able to
select the right kinds of patients to
define the right kind of strategy for
outcomes and also to translate other
findings that are beyond the objectives
of the specific clinical trials
in other words even if clinical trials
have failed to
a meaningful insight for the next round
of clinical trials or for modification
and so a big trend in both of these is
the discovery of
biomarkers and these of course are
markers of specific conditions
markers of specific biological processes
and we are looking for more and more
precise
markers oftentimes what that means is
that
we are not relying on a very clear-cut
signal
but a complex signal and that complex
signal is
defined by the complexity of omics data
which could be of course of many
different types and has
many different ranges of values that we
can use
to combine into a signal signal and that
signal would be a integrated signal
essentially from multiple types of
omnics data
so what kinds of omics data are we going
to talk about we're going to talk about
phenomics
which is the characterization and the
features coming from
image analysis from clinical data from
cell morphology
we're going to be talking about genomic
data or the mutations
or collections of mutations found in the
dna
we'll be talking about epigenomic signal
where we'll discuss
chip seek data whole genome by sulfide
sequencing data
transcriptomic data including
gene expression levels of gene
expression transcript expression
alternative splicing and we will talk
about specific
examples where we will use this data to
actually discuss the objective
and the type of data that could be
analyzed
because every type of data comes with a
specific set of parameters that we need
to consider
when we are trying to set up and plan
our
analysis and of course one of the major
challenges
in this whole field of onyx is that the
data is actually
unstructured right so as you
look at the availability of data and the
type of data that is being generated
more and more
this is going to be unstructured data
because
structured data requires processing
so if you think about collection of
biological samples from patients or even
generating that data as a high
throughput experiment
you end up with unstructured raw
reads you look at different types of
environmental conditions and because of
that
the first step that we're going to be
talking about is
processing that data or converting that
data from
raw to a structured format from
different types of biological material
that can generate
digital data to an actual organized
table that we can work with and so later
on i'll talk about some of the formats
that that data is stored in
so that we can discuss some of the more
technical
kind of structures for this data that we
will be looking at
but ultimately the objective of data
science
is to provide guidelines for different
steps
of data analysis which includes data
processing
as you can see right here exploratory
analysis
and the actual data analysis or
comparative data analysis or
sometimes modeling of that data and so
to go from
experiments to results those three steps
is what we will have to cover in this
program and talk about
data cleaning and processing formatting
it
for the specific type of analysis that
we would like to do
exploring data using visual methods and
tools
as well as looking at different types of
approaches for data mining
data analysis where we consider
different statistical
machine learning and deep learning
models and then
inference how do we actually test our
findings and
go back to where we started with so that
we can contextualize the findings and
actually
interpret meaningful results so what are
some of the
typical challenges in this process some
of the typical
challenges include analysis and
visual exploration of data where we can
use things like
principal component analysis or
clustering to really identify
some meaningful groups of objects based
on
all of the available data or based on an
extraction of data
oftentimes this also means looking at
taxonomic relationships where we can
combine
biological understanding of where the
data came from
with our ability to structure different
types of groups of data
in the patterns that we find so a lot of
the processing
specific to biological data actually
combines those two methods one
is just exploratory analysis on
aggregate of all the data that we have
including noise and signal
filtering for specific signal that is
statistically significant
or integration between taxonomy which is
a biological concept or a construct
and the actual analysis of similarity
based on the data availability that we
have
so because of that we are really looking
at
this collection of different types of
data
that also includes other types of data
and that could include
imaging clinical data chemical data
phenotypic data
and all of this data has to go through
this process
of preparation and organization
of this data into structured formats
which typically in the context of data
science
is going to become some form of a data
frame
and so the first thing that we will do
in this program
is we will discuss how to prepare
different types of structured data
objects
data frames vectors matrices arrays and
lists
from the data sources that we prepare in
the processing pipelines
and then we will talk about how to
meaningfully organize
this information so that we can look at
relationships between categorical data
continuous data
and other types of data that we need to
organize
in a visual format so that we can
meaningfully spot
some results that are of interest for
our analysis
so sometimes this means just summarizing
the data that we have
sometimes it's looking at patterns
overall
a lot of times it leads us to the need
for data preparation
and data preparation means that
oftentimes data comes in a format
of different statistical properties that
we have to change
before we actually can run an analysis
designed to deal
with a certain data distribution for
example oftentimes when we look at next
generation sequencing data for
transcriptomics we need to first
transform it
into a log normal scale to have a more
norm
normal distribution of course this is
not a universally applicable method
because
when we come to data sets that are for
example metagenomic data
there there typically is not a need to
make that transformation but instead we
need to choose
a completely different method of
analysis to extract
meaningful patterns now also when it
comes to
exploratory analysis we also need to
understand that
the majority of the data that we have
has
many different components and many
different sources of signal
that we could consider including
technical
including statistically significant
and including some non-statistically
significant but nevertheless
important for our ability to extract
meaningful portions of data
for downstream analysis and so that's
why we will also talk about
different methods of statistical
analysis including
t-tests f-tests anova
regression and other types of methods
that will
explain the relationship between
variables in our data
that we can ultimately use for
analysis and oftentimes we will find
that the statistical analysis has
limitations and the limitations come
from
several different types of sources so
one
is the variability in our data is
complex
and we cannot capture that complexity
using
standard statistical techniques because
of low p
values and kind of complexity
of the differences between noise and
signal
it also can come from just the
types of data because we might deal with
many different types
with many different variables that we
cannot connect into a single data set
and so that is really where we will turn
to the topic of data mining
and classification we're looking at many
different
types of methods that are typically used
for analysis
for classification and for feature
selection
so we will look at different examples of
methods like decision trees support
vector machines
hierarchical or k-means clustering
including
clustering for big data sets like pam
fuzzy and dbscan we'll look at linear
discriminatory analysis
and other types of methods that will
help us use
this predictive analysis for
inference for feature selection and
something that we can ultimately
interpret
we will also dig deep into the
algorithmic properties of some of these
methods to really understand
how different approaches can help
extract
features that are responsible for
discrimination between different types
and different classes and so we'll talk
about
methods of feature selection including
support vector machines and random
forest for
feature significance as well as greedy
methods of analysis like stepwise
analysis of linear discriminatory
analysis
and such we will also talk about
an obvious topic that many are
interested in which is deep learning
applications in omix data so we will
talk a little bit about
different approaches for deep learning
uh how we can
discriminate between different types of
network topologies how we can optimize
some of the parameters
and ultimately what are the applications
where do these methods work well
and where these methods do not work well
and how do we
evaluate the performance and how can we
select the right type of method for the
right type of
project idea that we have now
importantly
many of these methods come with
ready-made packages
and with practical exercises that you
will be
able to run so we have prepared a
collection of
scripts and curated data sets where you
will be able to try
and run the specific analysis of your
choice understanding
the methods and their application in the
context of what's called a package a
package that might combine
many different specific scripts and
algorithms to extract some meaningful
insights that is considered to be a
standard
in a particular field as you can see
here this is the application of
non-metric dimensionality scaling in mds
for taxonomic analysis of microbiome
data so we'll discuss these methods
that really tend to combine multiple
methods of visualization of
processing of data analysis and then
translation translating that into
biologically interpretable results
now uh what we will do in terms of
your technical skills is we will
introduce a number of different
techniques and technologies to allow you
to understand and appreciate the
implementation of these methods
and so for coding we will use both r and
python
we will introduce you to a number of
different environments where you can run
this code including
integrated development environments like
rstudio
or visual studio for r and for python
respectively we will talk about sharing
your code
how do you effectively share your code
using jupyter
notebooks how to post your data on
github how to create
google colab notebooks that you can
share and run your code in those as well
but ultimately you will get a
sense or a landscape of these different
methods and tools
including some commonly used libraries
and packages like the base in r or
ggplot specific packages like gg
fortify and ggpu br you will be able to
look pi
uh to use python pandas numpy and sk
learn packages including visualization
in matplotlib and seaborn and you will
be able to
apply general coding practices that are
going to be important
as you develop your skills in
bioinformatics and that includes
organizing your scripts using comments
and functions
setting up the development environment
dealing with
errors and troubleshooting your code so
learning how to
interpret the errors and finding the
reasons for the errors
and then how to prepare your data
summaries and submitting curated data
and metadata tables to sharing
repositories like on github or
dataverse and we'll use jupyter
notebooks on github and google collab
including will pre create some
interactive visualization using plot
links so
these are the topics that we plan to
cover from the technical side
but to really draw the connection
between
the technical and the conceptual we will
utilize
a number of projects and these are
curated projects that our team has gone
through
has annotated for the specific methods
that the authors of
peer-reviewed articles have used and
extracted
some examples from these data sets so
that we can try and practice on them
both learning about the usefulness of a
method
but also being able to understand why
this method is being used
and how to interpret the results or how
to use the results
from such a data science approach now
these different projects include many
different categories so many different
data types including genomics
epigenomics metagenomics transcriptomics
many different types of
projects like projects and neuroscience
and cancer
infectious diseases and ultimately this
also will be applicable to a project
that you can
independently develop because once you
understand the data
and the needs to transform and
understand the data to
for analysis you can then actually apply
the same techniques
to a data set of your own now that data
set could be found on the public
repository
or it could be something that you
actually are already working on
so your own data set as well
okay so let me pause here and try to
address some of the questions so
if you have any questions please feel
free to post your questions
in the chat and i will go one by one and
address some of the questions
so the first question that i see here is
about
different programming that i have used
or that we will use in this program
so first of all we will go through i
will go through several examples in
today's session
of processing big data using the t-band
for platform
how to download from that portal
some r scripts that you can modify and
use
then i will introduce you to a number of
scripts in r
and in python so that you can see how
you can learn those as well
and then the other question that i see
here is can we publish our results in
journals using
secondary data so obviously yes you can
there are many
examples of re-analysis it's called
meta-analysis or re-analysis of existing
publicly available data sets
typically about 95 of the actual
data is not being published it's only
the five percent of the most significant
exciting or relevant findings that
people tend to put in the journal
article
but that means that 95 of that data is
still available for
re-analysis and oftentimes you can
actually take and combine multiple data
sets
integrate them into a new data set and
ask a completely different
question or even perform the
similar analysis using different methods
and that oftentimes will lead to novel
insights
might mean to something it might mean
that you can find
something that you know could have some
significance and and if you do
then you can actually share that in a
journal
article of course we do not commit to
helping you go
through the submission we just can help
you by training
and offering you guidance in how to
develop a bioinformatics project
okay so uh hadiya is also asking if the
course will be recorded
yes i will come to that in a second uh
this session
is being recorded it's also being live
streamed on youtube so you can always
find it on our youtube channel
but i will talk a little bit about the
sessions that we will cut
we will cover in the full program and so
those yes will be recorded and shared
with all the participants
are there basic courses for a biologist
who doesn't have computational skills
such as arm python from
lingaraju so yes i think that
we live in an era of data science and so
it's critical
for anyone who has an interest in
applying data analysis to large data
sets to
learn gradually some of the required
data science skills
including coding and so that's why this
program
i think will be also useful for those of
you that do not have
the skills to to code already but want
to acquire those skills
so that's really what the program is
about i think it's also going to be
useful for those of you that do know
some coding
but would like to learn a little bit
more about machine learning deep
learning
and how to visualize and explore your
data and so i think to
explain how the program can achieve all
of that in a short time
i would like to demonstrate to you how
the program will run
and what are the different components of
knowing how to ask a question being able
to
access big data sets and integrate them
and then how to apply some of these data
science skills
to also explore and use machine learning
on those data and and then demonstrate
your results share your results with
others
okay so if there are no other questions
thank you durba also for your interest
i think there are many applications in
agricultural sciences as well
we do have another session that's going
to be coming up about
agriculture and the application in
agriculture but today
let's continue and talk about this
general field of data science
and see how we will achieve all of this
during this upcoming program
so the upcoming program will combine
three different things
that you will be able to do and the
first one is interactive sessions just
like today
you will be able to join a session on
zoom and one of our mentors myself
clinton or harpreet will be guiding
these different sessions that you can
interact with us and with others ask
questions
get help with some technical challenges
that are being
um that you're getting stuck with
and then also to get the assignments and
the review
for your completed assignment so that
will be covered in the interactive
sessions
included will be some self-guided study
materials so these self-study
materials that we offer is something
that i will show in just a few minutes
and then we will also use some tools and
these tools include
the t-biome for platform many of you are
already familiar with that
it's a logical and user-friendly
way to analyze all kinds of omics data
including
genomics transcriptomics epigenomics
and metagenomics and then we will turn
to
our coding portal where you will be able
to
try different scripts including scripts
that you've used on the platform i'll
demonstrate that in a few minutes
so that you can understand not only how
this platform works but also
what is the specific code and how to
modify that code
and practice so that you can test
whether you understood or not
so i will demonstrate that in a second
so at this point maybe i can ask all of
you
how many of you already have an account
on
learn omixlogic.com
all right excellent durba if you do not
have an account
yet please take a moment to
register so let me show you
how you can register on this portal
this portal is something that will be
important if you would like to
try some of the things that we're going
to be doing today
that is going to be very useful so if
you already have an account
you can go ahead and log in to your
account if you do not have an account
you can create one
by clicking right here
and so let me log in and i will show you
a couple of examples that we will be
going through
that anyone can try starting with today
okay please let me know once the rest of
you have
logged in i will give it a moment
all right thank you zara shifa
abeer and durba okay great so
if you're not yet registered on this
portal please take a moment to
register and log in and then
once you log in you will be able to see
right here on top is the menu and there
are some courses
programs and also right here is your
account okay so when you log in
we ask that you go into this account
into your account and you look at
updating your profile as well
as looking right here that you have a
subscription so i will go over some of
these things today but this is just
to help you find all this information on
your
profile okay excellent so i see that
some of you
are registering right now once you have
registered
again you can go to the menu and find
your
email right here so you can go to your
profile
so once you've registered please put
something in the chat box so i
know um i'll i'll just give it another
couple of minutes
for everyone else to join in
all right thank you hidayah
all right great arpita thank you
again the objective today is to talk
about the program that is coming up but
also to give you a sense of how things
will work so
um thank you okay okay so great so now
we have
quite a number of you already registered
so let's take a look at an example of
what i'm talking about
when i say we can practice both by
running a big data analysis and then
taking that modifying the script and
actually learning
how the script works so if you go to the
courses tab
you will see here first of all a brief
overview of your profile
and then you will see here you can
search for different courses
so let's search for introduction
to data science and you can select
either introduction to data science
in python or you can actually
look for introduction to data science
and r
and so for today's purposes i will take
an example
from r but you can perform all the same
analysis in python as well and we will
cover that also
okay so if you are already logged in
okay thank you i see
shifa or peta okay so i see a lot of you
are now logged in
so again if you are here i would like to
show you
how this will practically work
okay and so please go to this first
r coding introduction to data science
course
and once once you are here we're going
to look we
will take it kind of to the advanced
level so you get a sense of what we will
be doing
ultimately but if you don't know the
basics there are some basic
methods here as well so let's go right
here into dimensionality reduction
so how many of you are familiar with
principal component analysis
already let me know in the chat
how many of you are familiar with what
is principal component analysis
okay added io excellent thank you anyone
else
durba okay excellent
a beer is not okay so for those of you
that
are familiar with principal component
analysis
you know that sometimes principal
component analysis can give you a
general sense
of differences between different data
types
or sorry object types right so
sample types for those of you that are
not familiar i will briefly explain
so let's say we have a gene expression
table
and this gene expression table contains
some samples we have a header
in the table it has some sample names
these samples belong to different
categories so different groups
like normal like basal luminal etc so
this is by the way
a table of gene expression for breast
cancer cell lines
now these different subtypes of cancer
are important to understand because
ultimately
they can be treated by different types
of drugs
more effectively so if we have a tumor
and we want to understand what's the
best way to treat that tumor
we need to classify them organizing them
into different subtypes
so here we have 15 different genes and
a number of different cell lines many
different cell lines and our objective
here
is to understand whether we can see the
differences between these different
subtypes
here you can learn a little bit about
what this means
and you even have a short video to
introduce the full code if you would
like to learn
afterwards the second thing that you
need to do is
you need to load a library and the
library here is important because as i
mentioned
principal component analysis is a type
of a machine learning method it's
dimensionality reduction but it could be
used
with many additional scripts not only to
perform the analysis but also to give us
a meaningful visualization
that will become intuitive as we take a
look at the data
so first we need to load a library like
that and a library like that
exists already and there are many
different packages that can
add on some meaningful visualization
tools for
downstream analysis now the second thing
that we need to do
is we need to use a data set that we can
load and you can see that it's actually
really simple once you kind of learn to
read the code
it's very intuitive we create a an
object called input file and we place in
this object
some path to the actual data set
once we do that we actually translate
the input data into a
an object that will be
in in imported using a specific method
and so here we can use a read table
method or we can use
read csv or read txt so different
methods to actually
load in the data from that file
and then we want to create a matrix so
those of you that are already familiar
with r and python
what is the difference between a matrix
and a data frame could you please tell
me
okay can anyone tell me what is the
difference between a matrix
and a data frame
at a time thank you the matrix has only
one data type numeric and data frame has
different data types
excellent so as we saw
this file contains multiple
data types here it includes numbers
and here it includes strings so it
includes
names that include numbers and letters
and so that's why the analysis has to be
separately done
on just the numeric data but the
annotation has to be done
using all of the other information and
so here what we're doing
in this code is we need to separate one
from the other
and then we can actually analyze this
data
and so as you go through this example
you can see that
the analysis itself is something very
simple it's just one line of code but
this analysis produces multiple types of
output
based on what we loaded in and how we
organize the different objects
and then you can play around with what
your output is
from this analysis which is by the way a
function that you will
use that somebody else wrote and then
you can see
that you can add on all kinds of useful
elements to the output
to understand the separation between
different types of objects or different
types of cell lines
including what genes are most
informative
for the separation into different groups
now to perform this analysis yourself
you can also try
running this analysis right here in
this coding area okay so
if you now go to this step number three
you will see that the input file is
given from
github so we have some github link
then we prepare the full table
separate the matrix filtering for some
data that we don't need
then we perform the actual
object we perform the analysis and we
plot the result and once we do that
we can use different types of libraries
to actually make this
visualization a little bit more
informative and so the cool thing about
this is i can
run this code right here in the browser
to
change different things about the code
and to see the result right here in the
output so i've run the analysis and i
can try
the base r as well as a
ggplot output that provides me with some
additional useful information
what could be nice here before i
kind of continue on is to add some
additional
information using an additional
method of annotation
okay so that we can actually run and so
that's where we
go from the learning about code to an
actual
challenge so you've learned the code
right the code
runs we know that it works now let's try
to modify this code
so that we can add some additional
elements that could be useful for
visualization so if i
just click on run i get an error and you
can see that it has an
unparsable argument library gg45 okay
so right from the start this is not
working so now i have to learn how to
troubleshoot this
and also include some additional code
that now i can make into a working
script
so that i can make some better
visualization of data and understand
all of the different outputs about this
method so ultimately
what you will be creating as you figure
out this challenge
is a visualization of a principal
component analysis of a next generation
sequencing transcriptomic data set
about breast cancer that clearly
separates into meaningful groups
depending on the angle of the final
output
right and so to learn about all of these
different methods
that is why you need to go through the
training sessions to know
what are the specifics of the code what
are the specifics of the actual method
or how it works and what does it mean
as well as some biologically meaningful
understanding
of what is the context of this data and
what is the need
for making such analysis or in other
words how can we actually
interpret what we have here in our data
okay even after this you can go beyond
the basics
and start including some additional
information about statistical
significance
of separation including clustering
how you can cluster this information and
all the way
into feature significance as we already
discussed
so that we can make this even more
interpretable and so
that is a huge component of this program
that we will not only look at some of
the kind of conceptual things but you
will get to practice and learn
how to perform all of these meaningful
analyses
using a number of different tools for
loading data and checking what
is in the data data visualization
including some advanced visualization
techniques principal component analysis
differential gene expression clustering
classification
and even things like tc so you can
actually look here
at also some statistical analysis tests
so you can take a look at some of these
lessons now i mentioned
in your profile right here if you go
back
you need to have a subscription so if
you want to
learn about all of these methods you
don't even have to join the full program
you can
use some of these methods in a
synchronous way practicing
independently and all you need is a
starter subscription
so this subscription is designed to be
very affordable
for those of you that would like to get
started and
are not ready to join the program so all
you need to do is you need to go to
the pricing tab and select the basic
starter package it's only ten dollars a
month and you can get started with this
program
already now another important component
of this of this
whole program is how
did we generate this table right so i
already talked about
generating the table from unstructured
data because most of the data sets that
you will find online
are actually unstructured and so to
briefly explain the connection between
the raw data
and this small table that we already
worked with in this online example
let me introduce you to our big data
analysis platform now i know that some
of you are already familiar with this
platform
but i will also show you today how you
can run an analysis
on the t-biome for platform and download
directly the r
script that is used for the analysis
itself
so that you can open it up right there
in the omixlogic
portal and run the same code that you
download from the platform
okay so please go with me to this other
link called
server t-bioinfo
if you have created an account you
should be able to use the same login
information
as you created on the logic onyx logic
portal
for those of you that created the
account today you will be able to use
that 24 hours from now so tomorrow
okay so if you don't have your login
just yet
you can come back and practice this
tomorrow
okay so here i want to show you a couple
of short examples and these are going to
be demos
so we're not going to be loading the
data but i will quickly show you how to
go from raw data to structure data
and then perform the same principle
component analysis that we did here
but directly from the download from this
portal
if i go to the first demo right here
under transcriptomic data remember we
took here transcriptomic data
i can learn about transcriptomic data
analysis conceptually just by following
this example
so this example separates the full
analysis into three sections
pre-processing mapping and
quantification
once i do that i can follow that those
steps to perform
what's called to make a pipeline build a
full pipeline
so as you remember the first step was
pre-processing and it was blue
so i can select trim-o-matic which trims
the reeds from
technical adapters pcr clean which then
eliminates the
amplification using bridge pcr
amplification which is a part of the
sequencing process
i can then map the reads that i've
cleaned up
onto the reference genome create
a new gtf file that contains all the
information about the transcriptome or
what are the actual
transcripts being expressed in my data
set
and not just what's in the database and
then i need to
map again the reads onto these annotated
transcripts
and quantify using
rna-seq using expectation maximization
which
in itself is a machine learning process
that
looks at the statistically significant
values for those read abundances across
the whole
transcriptome so now that i've performed
this analysis
i can also take a look at the outputs
so here i have those genes that we
looked at
according to the different samples and
groups of samples that we
already generated and looked at in the
previous example
now what can i do with this data we
looked at the coding
example now let's take a look at an
example
right here which helps us understand the
conceptual link between
inputs and outputs that we are expecting
to find so right here i have an
unsupervised analysis pipeline that
shows
different examples for uh what we just
did
right so here is a good place to kind of
see
what are the categories of the different
methods that we
use typically for exploration of
biomedical data
including omix data and so here you can
see
that we have a simple pipeline
using an r script and piece for pca
and all i need to do is just download
the result
because one of the results is the actual
package for r right so remember one of
the objectives here
is not just to learn about the scripting
but also for effective organization of
your code and so effective organization
of your code can be seen right here
essentially any executable script
typically is stored in a package and
it's written in the language
that is used to run that script
and so that is right here the actual
script is right here i can open the
script
and i can read what it does and it's
organized very differently from the
script that we just edited
on the platform right how different is
it
number one it includes some arguments
and these arguments
are being passed from outside the script
if you just
run this script in r it's not going to
generate anything
there are some arguments that first of
all need to be addressed
to run the script from the command line
and so here you can see arguments for
input file
for whether to transpose the file to
center and scale it and also
what number of axes to draw
and the second file that you have is an
actual call file that you can run from
your terminal
to launch the r script together with the
specific data set
that is explained right here so this
data set
has a name and it's a dot txt and then
you can see
all of your other arguments passed right
here in the script line
so this is an important part of what we
will learn in this program as well
so we will talk about how the data is
generated
you will be familiar with this interface
so that you can try out some of these
things
on your own you will see that
this includes processing of many
different types of data
it includes analysis of next generation
sequencing mass effect data
some methods for structural data
analysis and then
importantly you will find a whole
section dedicated to data mining data
visualization
and integration as well and so
here you will find an interface that
allows you to take
huge data sets up to five terabytes in
size and analyze them using this
visually intuitive interface that
includes
helpful guides on how to
get the types of outputs that you need
and importantly
this spans across many different types
of analysis
from sequence alignment to variant
calling to evolutionary studies
to chip seek and whole genome by sulfate
sequencing data
so all kinds of methods are including
included here
and as i mentioned many of these could
then be opened up right there in the
script runner
so that you can analyze this data and
practice the analysis yourself
seeing the correct output and some
tutorials with step-by-step explanations
on how to get to the desired output
now ultimately we will also go about how
to transition from this online
experience
to actually setting up your development
environment right there
on your computer so that you can
install the right libraries and packages
to run the
analysis in r or in python in visual
studio
or in our studio does anyone have
any questions about what we did in this
section
zara i hope that i answered your
question on how this table could be
generated
and if you have any other questions
please feel free to write this
in the chat so that i can address your
questions one by one
okay if there are no other questions
then feel free to add more questions
if i have not addressed them yet i want
to briefly describe
what will be the schedule for the full
program so the program will start
on monday july 12th and
we will start this program in two parts
the first part we'll talk about the
introduction to big data so
what are the different types of data
what are some of the big data challenges
and opportunities
how to clean load and process data how
to perform exploratory data analysis
and then we'll do some practical
training so that we can all try out
these methods together
okay so briefly we do have a question
from christina she's saying
i've just introduced the resources
available with the starter subscription
the starter subscription will give you
access to the demo pipelines that i just
showed
and to running the code the program will
actually open up the platform for you to
load data sets
and we'll go through ncbi and tcga and
places like that to
take curated data sets and process them
and then analyze them together
so the program subscription will give
you a higher level of access
and it's going to be a little bit more
expensive but i'll talk about that at
the end of today's session
let me know please if that answers your
question
so the program itself yes the starter
package
is a fully asynchronous training package
that you can use to understand how the
two are connected and to practice some
coding
and learn about different types of data
sets the program
will include synchronous sessions
sessions like today that are interactive
where you can ask questions and get
practical help
where you will also get much more
in-depth information than is
what is provided in the courses and what
we found is that
this is really needed to master a
subject because so many online courses
lack the guidance and the structure and
so that's why we created these programs
to provide with that structure and
mentorship
so that you can interact with a live
person and get unstuck
before you get into the program and the
program will be organized into two parts
the first part is going to be an
introduction and the second part is
going to be focused on machine learning
itself
so we'll talk about what is the
difference between machine learning and
ai
what are the different methods for
supervised and unsupervised learning
and then we'll talk about how to deal
with the multiple types of models that
are available there i mean
there are so many methods they all work
in a very similar way
how do you effectively choose between
them and select the one that will work
for the type of project that you have
and the type of objectives that you are
pursuing
in your own project and that's going to
be another important component
is that according to the levels of
learning
one of the highest levels of learning is
called
a project-based learning and so
project-based learning if you
really master something that means that
you can do
a project using those methods so you
will learn about a lot of different
methods
but to test yourself and to know that
you really mastered
you need to try and apply that to an
independent project and so that will be
another component of this program
program is we will help you apply this
to a project of your own and
guide you to refine your thinking about
when
and how and specifically what
does the specific analysis type that
you've chosen
address in the data set that you've
already selected that you also
select so it's going to be a flexible
thing that you can
try different data sets and try
different methods and then come up with
a research proposal and actually try and
execute it during the program
so i'll briefly review some of these
methods that i've discussed
the first part working with big
biomedical data
will include addressing some of the
different types of omics data
including different technologies that
are used to generate that data
we will then talk about what is the
difference between
small data and big data and what are
some additional data
challenges that we are supposed to
address and how does that change
our analysis practice how do we go from
kind of typical statistical analysis to
what is the need for machine learning
we'll then go through cleaning loading
and
processing data so we'll talk about how
to prepare a table but also how to
explore that table
to know what to do with it and we will
also address some of the
important questions that arise out of
exploratory data analysis
so we look at statistical properties
we'll spot
batch effects and technical issues that
have to be
removed and addressed before we actually
start the analysis
and then we'll take a look at several
examples of how
this ties into a workflow so how to
essentially design your workflow
from acquiring data from different
repositories
to preparing a structured data for
analysis
one of the questions and maybe i can ask
this of you as well
is well transcriptomic data in a sense
is
easy right transcriptomic data is
continuous
and so the numbers are right there in
the table
but what to do with data that is
naturally categorical for example here
you have sequences of t c g and a so
essentially numbers one two three and
four
how do we deal with data that is like
that to convert it
to data that is continuous that is most
useful for some of these machine
learning methods
and so the answer to that of course is
that there are many different ways that
we can convert data from categorical
to continuous and once we've done that
we need to incorporate that step of how
we convert it to data
so that our analysis matches the type of
preparation that we did
now in the second part we will talk
about data-driven analysis and that's
really where machine learning comes into
play
is because we generate a hypothesis from
data
and then we build an algorithm
oftentimes
not really diving too deep into the
biology before we can train a model
that could have some meaningful value
right
and so this is a huge change from the
traditional approach to data analysis
coming from biological experimental
design
because we are essentially not trying to
test the hypothesis
we are trying to design an algorithm
that could mean
something useful either for
understanding or
for a practical use and i think that's
one of the major
kind of advantages of machine learning
in that sense because
we essentially can not understand
everything but still
find use in the data that is generated
so we'll talk about
what is machine learning and how is it
different from artificial intelligence
we'll turn to unsupervised learning
we'll where we'll talk about different
types of clustering techniques
and what do they mean what do they
provide us with
we will talk about supervised analysis
for classification
and feature selection so that we can
understand
different algorithms different types of
models and
what are they essentially able to
provide us with
we will then talk about evaluating the
different models and the outputs through
model accuracy and validation we'll talk
about rock curves and area under curve
we'll talk about
also how to interpret some of the
results from
our analysis and how to then use these
metrics to select
the right model for what we want to
achieve
we will then talk about machine learning
to get results right so one thing is to
understand how these methods work
another one is to actually make them
work right and that's where you have to
build essentially a pipeline
and make sure that you are including all
of these important steps
into that pipeline and also so that you
have a full description of your full
code that you can share with others that
would like to try
and replicate what you have done so we
will address this important topic in
biomedical research
which has to do with reproducibility so
what are you going to learn by joining
specifically this program
and here we've listed out some of the
things that we think
are critical for anyone that would like
to learn
biomedical data science for biomedical
discovery
and that includes learning by looking at
examples of data visualization
and learning about different types of
approaches and packages for machine
learning and r
and python looking at some curated data
sets and by curated i mean these were
selected from
peer-reviewed papers they contain uh
interesting kind of questions and
interesting results as well so we can
validate the analysis
you will learn about stage of stages of
analysis
exploratory comparative supervised and
unsupervised
we'll talk about different types of
machine learning algorithms
so that you understand the taxonomy and
how to read and understand different
methods
you'll also learn about fair principles
of how to
describe your analysis and share your
workflow
and you will also learn about project
design
and implementation for independent
research and i will point you to a
course actually that we have there
that can help you streamline your
bioinformatics analysis
okay a question from hidayah is it
suitable for a beginner
yes you do not need to know how to use r
if you followed our previous steps you
probably
saw that there's some asynchronous
coursework on the very basics of r how
to
learn about it so if you are not
intimidated if you're brave and you are
up for the challenge
then this is definitely for you if you
feel like this is technically very
complex
i would recommend that you first try so
if you have some time today or tomorrow
over the weekend
you can try out some of these
asynchronous courses some of them are
free
and if it seems like something that you
can manage then definitely this is for
you
and please let me know if i answered
your question
now there are some additional benefits
that i won't go
into right now you can see them on the
screen but i do want to mention
this part of the independent project
right so as i mentioned
to really learn and master a skill
you typically have to go beyond just
reading a textbook and trying out a few
pieces of code so really it's all about
applying these methods that you've
learned to an independent project
and so to do that we've designed a
system
to help you apply the data that
we have curated or that you can find
with methods that you will learn about
or additional methods that you have
heard about or read about
to a project where you can modify the
settings
and the question that you have and
essentially come out
with a fully independent project and we
have many examples of people that have
completed
a similar program and have come out with
a fully completed project
that they have shared and went on to
publishing
so let me show you what that means
on the same portal
if you look under courses
you will be able to find a project
or sorry a course about developing
an independent project called designing
a bioinformatics research project and
this is
essentially a cornerstone of our
project driven method that helps
translate these
practical skills into an outcome
that is relevant for research so a lot
of the participants that we have here
are researchers or
interested in research and to help them
start applying bioinformatics in a
meaningful way
we've designed this guide that
essentially goes from
finding a real interesting
and competitive research topic through
literature review
to then finding a data set on different
public domain repositories
and then all the way to finalizing your
analysis and presenting this
so that you are ready for publication so
this is all a part of our strategy
and if you go to your profile you will
see
how all of these things actually connect
so the first one is training
right here under your profile you will
find a tab
called courses and you'll be able to see
that
you have a number of courses that you
can go through
complete them and get a certificate for
completing that individual course
so if you click here it will open up and
show your certificate
the second one is in many cases it's not
enough to go through the material
independently you really have to have
someone that guides you
in a structure to get you from point a
to point b
and that is where these programs come in
now you might be
advanced and interested in machine
learning or you might be just a beginner
and just getting started
and based on where you are we've
designed specific programs to help you
get started from where you are
and get you to the next level so if
you're ready to join this program
go to lvrn on my logic data science if
you would like to just get started and
learn about
what is going on with bioinformatics we
recommend another program
called omixlogic bioinformatics and
computational biology a cheap and
affordable program for anyone interested
to get started
but ultimately we would like you to be
able to design
an independent project and so we have
these multiple steps that you have to
follow
to be able to get there you have to
complete your profile
your bio earn 10 000 points
which you acquire by going through the
different projects and the different
challenges along the way and then you
will be able to complete this course
that i just showed you
where all of the steps are given and you
can submit
a project proposal that will be reviewed
by our team
and then go through all the steps needed
to complete your analysis
and present as a research fellow
and so that's why an additional program
that we have for those of you that
already know everything that there is to
know and you would like to work on an
independent project
exclusively we have another specific
program called
a research fellowship and this program
is designed
to actually help you learn
and work on your independent
i'm sorry on your independent uh project
along the way so i'm just going to post
this link right here
for those of you that are interested in
more of a research approach to this
whole thing
this is a program that could be between
three months and
six months and during that time we are
confident that you can get to a
meaningful outcome
including a full project proposal and
presentation okay
so that is what i wanted to cover
we have a number of examples of people
that have completed this program and
have started using some of the
bioinformatics tools
and data science skills in their
research we do have
a lot of these examples already on the
website so you can look at those
as well and if you do have any questions
i would love to answer any questions or
concerns that you might have
so that all of you can join on
monday and learn with us
about data science so if you do have any
questions
please put them in the chat i will keep
this slide
on the screen for just a few more
minutes and if you don't have any
questions
then i welcome you to join how do you
actually
join the program so again this program
is uh lbrn data science that is going to
come up
let me find it
okay for anyone that has concerns about
what will happen once you complete the
registration so what will happen is you
will see
the program like i do and you will be
able to see
inside all of the zoom links
as well as recorded videos from past
sessions you will see that included
courses and projects
in this program and you will also be
able to get a certificate for the
program
after you complete the necessary steps
which includes
some of the sessions that you need to
complete
and some of the coursework that we
provide
all right great thank you aviva and
great to see you
looking forward to seeing um
singing aviva in the cohort
okay christine is asking would this be
the
program for intermediate level
experience with bioinformatics and
inside applications to genomics and
transcriptomics
yes so again you can join the program
as a complete beginner that's fine as
well
but mostly this is for people that do
have some
sense of what is this data and what they
want to do with this data so if you
don't have a lot of experience with
genomics and transcriptomics data this
is a great program for you as well
but it will be talking a lot about the
technical details as well so you have to
be prepared to
you know i don't know christina if you
know any r and python already
or are you just getting started so maybe
you could clarify that for me
hidayah is asking how many hours per day
so each session here and here you have a
schedule
each session is an hour and a half so an
hour of going through the lecture
materials and trying out different
things and then a half an
hour that we allocate towards q a so
it's an hour and a half
beyond this hour and a half a day you
also have
access to our slack channel and our
mentor community will be able to
assist you with any questions and if you
purchase the intermediate level
you can also book a meeting with one of
our mentors to help address one of the
questions that you have
okay so christina if you already have
some r experience and you're getting
started with python that this is perfect
for you
you will be able to take those skills
further as you also learn about the
different omics data types and what to
do with them
okay all right great so thank you
everyone again for joining
if you do have any final questions we
welcome you to email
marketing at omixlogic.com
uh you can also reach out directly to
mohit at behind.bio and he's going to be
overseeing some of the
logistics and then we also have sonalika
ray
and some of our campus ambassadors that
can help answer your questions directly
so if you do have
an email coming from marketing at
onyxlogic.com
you will be able to respond to that
email and actually get a reply
i do welcome you to register once you
register on the portal
and have your account it will be much
easier for you to join the program
and our next session is going to be on
monday in the afternoon
starting at 3 p.m so looking forward to
seeing you there
and have a great weekend everyone
you